-Welcome back.
I'm here with Hillary
and Chelsea Clinton.
Now, as --
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're gonna get to why Hillary
is wearing these headphones.
As mother and daughter,
I know that you're very close,
but I want to see
just how close you are
in a game that we call
"The Mother/Daughter Challenge."
Here's how the game works.
One of you will wear
the noise-canceling headphones
while the other answers
a question about you.
And then,
you'll take off the headphones,
and we'll see
if your answer matches.
-Okay.
-If it does, you get a point.
Very good?
-Do we get a prize?
-Yeah -- What's that?
-Do I get a prize if I win?
-Uh, yeah, you --
-A suitcase.
-Yeah, the love of your mother.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I hope I get that.
I don't know.
-Now, it's gonna get loud.
-Oh.
-Ready?
It's gonna get loud.
Here we go. Hold on.
Tell me whe-- you heard it.
-Oh, my gosh!
-All right, very good.
So you can't hear.
Very good.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Ready, Chelsea?
-Okay, I'm ready.
-What song would your mom sing
at karaoke?
-I think she only knows
the words to "Moon River."
[ Laughter ]
I think that's the only song --
-Is that even at a karaoke?
-I don't know.
I think it's the only song
she knows the words to.
The Roots are laughing.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, hold on a second.
All right, very good.
All right --
No, take it off.
-Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
-You're getting into the song.
-Whoa!
-All right, the question was,
what song would you sing
at karaoke?
-And she answered it?
-Yes.
-Oh, okay.
[ Light laughter ]
Well, probably the only song
she ever heard me sing.
-Hmm, okay.
-I used to sing to her
when she was a baby.
-Okay.
-And I sang the same song.
We would sit in a little chair,
we'd look out the window,
look at the moon,
I'd sing "Moon River."
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's exactly right!
I love "Moon River."
I love it.
That's a beautiful song.
Chelsea, it is your turn.
-Okay.
Oh, gosh, all right.
-It's gonna -- it's loud.
-It is. It's very loud.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
Ooh, you're into it.
Very good.
You want to give that
to Chelsea?
-Okay, here you go.
-Okay.
Okay. What is your craziest
family-vacation memory?
-Oh, we -- whew.
We had a lot of
kind of crazy times.
I'll tell you -- I hope
she doesn't remember this,
'cause it was pretty traumatic.
[ Laughter ]
-Those are the best stories.
-We took her to Russia --
Russia --
When we went on a state visit
when Bill was president.
-Yeah.
-And, you know, there's
the formal goodbyes, so Bill
and I were ushered into the,
you know, the beast,
the big limousine
to head to the airport,
not knowing
that we had left her behind.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-Wow!
-I mean, can you imagine...
-...leaving my only child
in the Kremlin,
especially with everything
that has happened?
[ Laughter ]
-Very good.
Here we go.
-That was a long answer.
-No, it's a good --
It's a goodie.
But it doesn't have to be long.
Maybe we added stuff.
-I'm trying to read your lips.
-No, okay.
-But I didn't succeed at all.
-My question was, what's the
craziest family vacation memory?
-Oh, gosh,
now I wish we had been, like,
chased by a bear or something.
[ Laughter ]
-Close.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Craziest...
[ Laughter ]
I feel like there's
a lot of shock over there.
-No.
No, not shock.
It's fun, it's fun.
-It's fun.
[ Laughter ]
When they left me
in the Kremlin.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
[ Ding! ]
♪♪
-You remember that?
Hillary and Chelsea Clinton,
everybody.
Their new docuseries, "Gutsy,"
will be available on Apple TV+
starting this Friday.